absolutely beautiful Here I am in East
Africa Uganda been doing some work out
in the rural parts of the villages which
has been fantastic but now I am in
Entebbe just enjoying a few days before
flying home in the last six months I've
been to six fabulous different countries
across Africa Asia Europe and the
amazing thing is that while I'm here I'm
still earning thousands of pounds every
single week from my passive income
through property but the reason for this
video is because in a few months ago we
sold out on our next property investors
crash course and I've been having a lot
of people message me really disgruntled
saying I sold out when's the next one
well while I'm here in East Africa
Uganda I'm going to make live the link
for you to reserve your plate at the
next property investors crash course so
on this email there will be a link for
you to book on I've already got a
massive waiting list of people ready to
book on so make sure you do it quickly
we always sell out why do we sell out
because the stuff that I'm teaching over
these two days are absolutely
life-changing they charge tens of
thousands of pounds elsewhere to learn
this stuff we're going to learn how to
buy properties with no money I bought
five houses in the last six months and
two of them I didn't pay a penny for I'm
also going to be teaching how to make a
thirty percent return on investment on
your money how to sauce bills flip deals
all kinds of stuff it's crazy strategies
in 2017 that work the stuff that I'm
teaching enabled me to retire at age 21
and now 26 travel the world making
hundreds of thousands of pounds every
single year being able to fund fantastic
projects out in Africa but also live a
really good lifestyle as well
the next warm it's going to be in July
in London on the 28th and 29th so get
yourself booked on right now the price
is ninety five pounds
we barely cover our costs because we are
in central London in the beautiful
Double Tree Hilton Hotel so what I would
say is reserve your place right now
avoid disappointment if you don't
reserve your place now please don't moan
at me in a month or two when the when
the program has completely sold out so
guys really
I do it if you already booked onto the
maze crash course I'll see it we're
gonna have an absolute blast and if you
want to come out with me to one of the
projects in Africa I do take some of my
students out once a year and although
it's incredibly humbling and rewarding
being in the villages we do also stay in
places like this so if you're interested
in that once you've been along to the
crash course let me know you can apply
more have a discussion so love you very
much and see you very soon